[Musique]
bonjour stéphanie est très heureux de
vous retrouver depuis washington
alors le sénat bonjour olivier alors le
sénat devrait donner le feu vert dans la
soirée à la nomination de la juge anne
icaunais bar est absolument olivier sans
surprise d'un les effets de sénateurs
devraient confirmer la nomination de
cette mère de sept enfants âgée de 48
ans de juge à la cour suprême au
fauteuil laissé vacant vous le savez par
ruth bader ginsburg décédé en septembre
dernier une simple formalité compte tenu
de la majorité républicaine
si des moyens du vent washington à
chaque chronique vous l'avez remarqué 53
sièges pour les républicains contre sens
dans cette enceinte
hier il faut savoir que la candidate de
trump a déjà obtenu 51 voix sur 48
insolent sénateurs il faut le préciser
républicains étaient toujours réticents
à donner sa voix à quelques semaines de
la présidentielle
il faut dire que l'enjeu est
considérable
selon donald trump lui même nommé un
juge suprême à la cour est née la
décision la plus importante que peut
faire un président américain
rien de rien que cela en tout cas donald
trump ne s'en est pas privé puisqu'il a
déjà renouvelé un tiers de la cour
suprême avec six juges conservateurs sur
neuf ça fait beaucoup
alors pourquoi est-ce aussi important et
bien parce que cette nouvelle juge avec
ses comparses aura pour mission de se
prononcer sur des sujets sociaux aussi
important par exemple que le
l'avortement on sait qu'elle est très
conservatrice 1 je le répète le mariage
homosexuel ou l'assurance santé
justement l'obamacare qui sera débattue
à la cour suprême
précisément à partir du 10 novembre et
c'est précisément ce qui inquiète
beaucoup les démocrates qui crient au
vol et qui sont très inquiets et écouté
elizabeth warren il ya 37 dure également
en es-tu mcconnell avait déclaré qu'il
ignorait le souhait le plus fervent
de ruth bader ginsburg et engagerait à
la procédure viciée et illégitime visant
à combler son poste à la cour suprême
oui jours à peine nous allons avant
l'élection alors que des dizaines de
millions d'américains ont déjà voté et
seulement 15 jours avant que la cour
supprime étudie un cas qui pourrait
infirmer la faux débat lequel mitch
mcconnell et leurs comparses et parti
républicain bafoue les souhaits du
peuple américain afin d'usurper ce siège
à la cour suprême
alors il n'ya pas l'obamacare il ya un
autre sujet qui est sur toutes les
lèvres et pour cause c'est l'élection
présidentielle elle-même vous le savez
vous l'avais dit à olivier tout à
l'heure près de 60 millions d'américains
ont déjà voté par correspondance
certainement raison de la pandémie et
donald trump lui met régulièrement en
garde contre justement une élection
truquée en cas d'invalidité le président
américain déjà déclaré qu'il
souhaiterait que les juges de la cour
suprême et leur mot à dire et tranche
justement les questions litigieuses et
at il précisé que la cour la juge bar
est justement soit en première ligne sur
ces sujets le chef de file des
républicains au sénat lui tient à
relativiser et préfère retenir les
compétences de la nouvelle juge pour
nous assurer le maintien de la
séparation des pouvoirs
garantir les droits des citoyens il nous
faut pour voir nos tribunaux avec des
personnes de très grande qualité
c'est une grande chance pour notre pays
que le sénat viennent de confirmer l'une
des candidates les plus qualifiés de
cette génération pour le service
judiciaire la juge amy koné barrettes de
la cour d'appel américaine du 7e ressort
est une candidate exceptionnelle sous
tous les aspects mais c'est tout aussi
important
madame barrette a fait preuve de son
refus absolu d'imposer ses opinions
personnelles ou de bricoler de nouvelles
politiques à coup de
cision de justice elle a manifesté
l'humilité devant la loi la neutralité
et la loyauté à notre constitution qui
sont essentiels pour ce poste à noter
que mike pence
le vice-président devait normalement un
présider cette séance de vote final ce
soir mais les sénateurs démocrates le
nom expressément demandé de s'abstenir
parce que figurez-vous que cinq proches
collaborateurs de ce vice présidents ont
été testés positifs au camp 8 19
alors en attendant stéphanie la campagne
se poursuit sur le terrain bien sûr mais
évidemment aussi dans les médias
stéphanie ah oui vous savez les médias
c'est très important ici et ça ne manque
pas
quotidiennement d'anecdotes
croustillantes il faut fouiller pour
faire le tri dernière petite anecdote de
campagne joe biden qui lors d'une
interview à la chaîne nbc diffusé ce
lundi a confondu son adversaire donald
trump avec un certain georges et côté
qu'elle sorte deux pays voulons nous
être quatre années supplémentaires de
george george nous allons nous retrouver
dans une situation où si donald trump
est élu nous serons dans un monde
fondamentalement différent voilà une
petite bourde qui est finalement passé
assez inaperçu ici aux états unis on
avait beau scruter et bbc cnn ou six
billets c'est bien aucune allusion à
cette bourdin de joe biden ce que n'a
pas manqué évidemment de remarquer à
donald trump qui en a profité
comme à son habitude pour critiquer les
médias mainstream joe biden m'a appelé
georges hier il ne se souvenait pas de
mon nom il a reçu de l'aide du
présentateur pour réussir l'interview le
cartel des fausses nouvelles fait des
heures supplémentaires pour le couvrir
et la campagne vous l'avez dit olivier
qui se poursuivent bien évidemment sur
le terrain enfin surtout il faut bien
dire pour donald trump
qui a aujourd'hui tenues pas moins de
trois meetings deux dans l'état clé de
la pennsylvanie et un autre en virginie
occidentale quant à joe biden et bien
rien pour le moment en tout cas rien
pour aujourd'hui à son agenda c'est la
même chose d'ailleurs pour sa colistière
kamala harris met à joe biden a prévu de
se rendre en floride cette semaine
merci beaucoup stéphanie nous faire
vivre au plus près du terrain cette
campagne et nous nous retrouvons bien
entendu dans nos prochaines émissions
pour continuer à suivre avec vous
l'élection présidentielle américaine